foreign
Audrey's in Lansing Michigan hey Audrey
what's up
well I really appreciate it sure how can
we help
um so my husband and I are facing a
little bit of like a moral dilemma um
we're just kind of looking for an
outside opinion on it
um so we we work at the same place right
now it
um a family business in the sense that a
lot of my family works there most of the
people who work there I'm related to
um we make a low income there right now
um and it's it's not what either of us
want to be doing long term I really want
to go to college and he wants to be a
chef
um but if we leave them we're leaving
them in a really bad position
um our business that didn't do well last
year so we're
just wanting to make sure that we're not
being selfish
um or just just trying to navigate
what's the right thing to do okay does
your family or his family own the
business
uh no my um my uncle is the manager of
this part of business the business as a
whole my family does not own okay
all right
so that that would relieve a lot of
moral dilemma
um I'm not sure there's a moral dilemma
anyway but anyway we relieve a lot of
the relational pressure
um it's not you're not harming your
family uh only the company needs your
help but they don't but they can't
afford you anymore
yeah we we make it enough to where they
never could have afforded you because
you make a low income
yeah we we
you told me you wanted to leave because
you had a low income now don't back out
on it
yeah
that's what you said I didn't say it
yes sir okay
how old are you guys Audrey
uh we're both 22. what do you make
um a little under 4 000 a month
each combined
combined I I can only work two days a
week I have a one-year-old so I'm at
home with him most of the time
okay so they're going to lose a
part-time employee
that they hardly pay anything
and they're going to lose an employee
that's 22 years old
yes sir I think they'll be okay
where are you feeling pressure Audrey
who is someone have there been
conversations or you guys are just
reading the story and thinking oh gosh
if we leave or is there is there outside
pressure is there anyone else in the
family that's like no Audrey you can't
you can't do this move
um
not really in that sense uh it's just a
lot of people have left recently even
though like it's such an amazing
business environment and everyone's
awesome it's just a lot of people have
less and we don't want to be another
couple people to I guess her everybody
says once people leave everyone else has
had to pick up so much of the slack
and I commend your you know selflessness
your your heart around this I think it's
a very
gracious
um mindset that you're in but also
Audrey you and your husband need to go
live your own lives if this is the
decision that you guys want to make for
you all you can't you can't be dependent
upon how everyone else is going to feel
in your life there's a point you have to
get that you're and that's not being
unkind the way you leave is is could be
unkind right so you can be gracious in
how you do that but the decisions you
make in your life yeah they have to be
for you lots of notice with a smile with
gratitude for the time I've been here
and um but I want to give you plenty of
now to show you because I know we've
lost some other folks I don't want to
leave you guys an alert so we're going
to give you a lot of notice
um maybe a month notice instead of two
weeks or instead of two minutes okay so
that's a lot of class and and the second
things I got a lot of class on is just
gratitude
uh thank you so much for what you meant
to us early in our lives here
and then can I have permission to be
mean for a second
yes sir okay if this business is
dependent upon a 22 year old and a
part-time 22 year old to make it it's
not gonna make it
if you're the last thing when you step
out causes this thing to fold up like a
tent it wasn't going to make it anyway
honey
yeah I I think I think they will yeah I
think we're probably just yeah y'all are
being very sensible yeah you're just
being very sensitive yeah I just what
I'm trying to say there is not to put
you guys down but I'm trying to say that
you're if if it comes down to uh one or
two people inside of Ramsey being here
or not being here whether Ramsay folds
up tent or whether Ramsay doesn't make
it then we were probably gonna make it
anyway
yeah and that's so you it just is and
they've been through a hard season I
hear you saying that a lot of people
have left so yeah they're feeling more
and more pressure so you're more and
more insensitive to that which is and
you've heard the family all talks about
the ones that left and you don't want to
be one of those but you're getting rid
of me and that's okay
and uh yeah you can't uh you can't be
responsible for how someone else decides
to
um interpret all of this you guys are
you're not being mean you're not being
unethical you're not being unkind you're
not being greedy you're not being any of
those things and and and anybody that
tries to put that on you guys is not
telling the truth okay so I would go in
with you and your husband sit down with
your uncle who's the manager and say hey
we're going to move on how can we do
that in a way that is the kindest to you
and to this place because we're so
grateful for this place
I mean do you want us to give you a
month's notice do you want us to leave
this minute
um what is the best thing for you all
because we're going to move on because
we can't make any money here this place
is struggling and you know we have other
dreams we're 22. my husband has a dream
yeah I'm being a chef I have a dream of
being this and we're going to go live
that dream and how can we do that that
is the kindest to you into this place
and we want to be classy help us to do
that teach us we're young uh you're
you're the old wise manager teach us how
we can be good uh how we can leave with
class because we're leaving
and if he tries to pull something that
causes you to stay just smile and say no
we're not going to be able to stay how
can we leave in a way that's going to be
the most helpful yep and you may have to
repeat yourself a couple of times it
sounds like
how does that feel Audrey
um no no that yeah I
um appreciate the
just knowing that it's not wrong I I
know that my uncle is one of the most
amazing people tell him that he'll be
very good at it yeah just tell him that
just say you know we admire you so much
the last thing we want to do is hurt you
we think you're one of the most amazing
people but that doesn't change our
decision yep I mean I've had people
leave here and they go you know Dave you
changed my life and you know my family's
changed because I got to work at Ramsey
and I will always be friends and thank
you you're an amazing leader and tell me
things like that as they're leaving and
then I've had other people give me the
bird and walk out the door you know so I
mean it's
um you know but you can you can you can
decide who you are it doesn't change who
I am right doesn't change who your uncle
is it you just said decide who you are
and that that's what we're telling you
to do yeah and I think it's a and I
think it's a healthy X for you and your
husband you guys are you're feeling this
nudge to go do something else and it
takes courage and maybe I mean at 22 I
know you know you have a little one and
all that but it you're continuing to
grow into yourself Audrey and into who
you guys are as a family you and your
husband I mean it's you're making these
adult-like steps and you're facing
adult-like conflict and decisions and
it's scary and it's uncomfortable so um
but it's you're good you're not morally
doing anything wrong so here I say that
what I want you to you started this
conversation stuck and I want you to
leave this conversation not being stuck
that's our goal okay you're not stuck
wave goodbye with a smile and do it now
not in a year
thanks for calling in hun